evan is in Tennessee
hi Evan welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hey thanks taking my call sure what's up
so in March of 2016 I was diagnosed with
cancer and as part of that I basically
just said screw it and focused 100% on
that what ended up happening was I got
this in my apartment my car got
repossessed and now that I'm all better
I've been back at work for quite a long
time well that's why I'm gonna be it's
pure luck that I was able to do it as
quickly as I did like I said more than
luck but I was gonna say beating cancer
wouldn't be called luck yes it would it
took a lot of intervention both
medically and divine yeah so now I'm at
the point where I can start getting
things back together I got a pretty good
job that gives me some great medical
benefits which was my number one concern
for very obvious reasons sure but now
I'm at the point where I need to start
getting the addiction taken care of and
start kind of cleaning up my records so
I can get I can get back to living
somewhat of a normal life that's how
much do you make now I make I gross
40,000 a year but after the insurance in
my medical care I come around 28,000
your insurance is $1,000 a month yes for
one person yeah okay
well that's pretty ridiculous in
Tennessee but so you're obviously not on
a group plan
I actually am but it's a relatively
small company it's about 200 people so
it's not a very well negotiated group
plan now so you have you price just
personally like a BlueCross BlueShield
policy I have and it'd be about 1213
three dollars a month and I wouldn't get
the coverage limits what I get with my
group plan yeah okay all right good okay
so you're making 40 you got 28 left over
after your health insurance and you want
to go back and clean up some of this
mess
do you have anything that is current
debt that you're paying on or is it all
about that it's all the old bad debts
and collections or been processed
nothing you've got an addiction and you
got a repo and you got some old medical
bills yes okay
how much is the as the eviction
contacted you I left the unit okay so
you don't know if you owe them anything
I do know that I owe them stuff because
it's on my credit report what's just
showing on the credit report 4500 it's
going on the credit report that's good
news all right and what about the car
repo what are they showing just under
7,500 so like 74 20 something that's it
okay how much in medical bills that's
actually the good news one of the I say
one of the benefits but one of the good
things that happens when you get cancer
is everybody comes out of woodwork to
help you so I've only got it roughly
about a thousand dollars in medical
bills and that from the last year okay
all right well let's let's just take
this in order of smallest to largest and
let's pay the medical bills as soon as
possible on your budget be clear of that
make sure if they're all any owe any
bills that are old bills always get in
writing that the amount you are sending
them clears the account okay you're
either paying it in full or you're
settling it or whatever but if I send
you this amount then I can send then the
account is cleared and you
keep that in hard copy form naughty form
print it off print it off and staple a
check to it showing or some kind of copy
of proof of payments showing that you
not only got from them this is what
clears the account but you cleared the
account by sending it to them and you
keep that in a file for the rest of your
life now then we'll go to the eviction
and I would just contact the management
company and you can always do better in
person especially on that one okay and
so what I would do is if you can meet
with the manager of the apartment
complex or wherever it was that you were
the company you're working with sit down
with them in person and not you know not
making any excuses I let it all go
because I was fighting cancer and I
should have been more responsible but I
was fighting cancer and so I've gotten
you know I've recovered from the cancer
that's in my past in my rearview mirror
so I'm trying to go back and make right
now my credit report shows $4,500 what
do your files show and what will you
take if I give it to you today in
settlement in lump sum okay and then if
they give you if they say $1,000 we'll
settle this then you hand them $1,000
and you get a receipt and you get it in
writing that that account is cleared for
that now the car repo you can probably
settle it for a quarter on the dollar I
have no idea what the landlord will do
they're all over the map they may want a
hundred percent they may look at you and
go this is five years ago I'm thought
I'd never see you again I'm so glad
you're here I'm sorry you had cancer
sure we'll take a grand and be done with
it or they may go we're adding fees to
this you know I don't know what they'll
do so but whatever you do do it in lump
sum and if they want more money than you
have you say I'll have to get back to
you and I've got the money but now at
least have a conversation going okay and
I can't give you more than I have and I
will not pay payments so just a little
bit of information that's kind of
driving me getting this together I'm
getting a six thousand dollar bonus in
January perfect so my goal was to get
the addiction knocked off her
because the eviction of keeping me from
writing certain places yeah but you can
get both that and you're not they're not
gonna they're gonna settle with you go
see them okay go sit down with them and
clear it clear the medical and clear the
eviction with the six thousand okay
you'll be able to clear both of them
with that and then you can start working
on I mean that how old is this repo the
repo happens in June of 2016 so it's
yeah half years old yeah they'll
probably take a dime on the dollar they
might take a grand - cuz they they can't
find you and they figure you didn't make
it I mean they're just gonna be happy
you show back up you know they're gonna
mouth about it you're gonna argue with
them but I bet you can get them take a
grand on that so you might be surprised
that quickly this all clears up for your
brother I'm sorry for what you've been
through thanks for calling in and thanks
for going and making it right